what's up thinkies what's up firing the
kiddies what's happening man
uh back on the road road dog thick road
dog is here next week tacoma washington
july 29th
through the 31st tacoma comedy club i'm
coming with the crew chappelle lacey
frickin uh my boy david lucas the whole
crew will be out in tacoma washington
next week thursday friday saturday july
29th through 31st
and then uh august i'm in north carolina
august 19th through the 21st that is
north carolina
and then just went on sale la jolla
comedy store
la jolla california august 27th through
the 29th
that's a friday saturday sunday we had a
sunday show
so two shows friday two show saturday
i'm sure we'll add shows to sunday
get your tickets la jolla those will
sell out quick so get them right now
august 27th to the 29th the comedy store
in la jolla your boys coming but next
week tacoma you're up thursday friday
saturday
tickets at fatkz.com or thickboy.com
this glorious episode of fighter and the
kid
is brought to you by on it on its
supplements
whatever your goal is in the fitness
world you're trying to lose weight
gain strength gain muscle you can't do
it by yourself
you need supplements man sure your your
diet's on point poppy
and you're losing weight but you need
help you need supplements man but you
need
the best supplements that's where onyx
comes into play let them help you
on your journey of fitness and health
and staying
thick but in shape thick you don't want
to be thick in the heart
what you need to do is get you some
supplements from
on it the best supplements on all of the
planet
what do you need man eat protein powders
check creatine check glutamine check
what do you need krill oil joint oil
check check
we got it all man we got alpha brain new
mood total gut health if your gut ain't
right nothing's right
we got nutrition for your ass we got mct
oil
we got protein bars protein bites we got
dark roast coffee some of my favorite
elk bars warrior bars protein power
puffs what's up daddy
who doesn't like power puffs these days
we have fitness
you don't need to leave your crib do it
from the comfort of your home but you
need some dope kettlebells the aunt
kettlebells
you can work out from home they're on
demand and streaming fitness programs
on it in six body weight program on it
in 30 move and groove morning mobility
whatever you need
battle ropes sandbags we got it all man
all you got to do is go to onit.com
fighter for 10 off the best supplements
the best
workout gear on the planet that's on it
dot com slash fighter for 10
off uh are you ready to start chin yeah
we're talking listen we're talking about
we need a mascot for the new studio well
the whole studio space is just not
finding the kids so we need a
we need a hound to roam the premises get
ourselves a junkyard dog now cause you
know the crime calabasas
it's skyrocketing bro we need
i need i need a dog a shepherd i want
not not a shepherd
i want i want to [ __ ] too much i want a
pimple and i want i want some ribs on
them but i want i want you can see some
of those dogs you see the backbone the
ribs but then you see
just their haunches and their shoulders
kind of like think about me as a dog
because there's no wasted space on me
there's no i don't drink anymore so
there's no wasted space on me dude well
you were drinking vacation last week
yeah well i've stopped
i haven't had a drink in like four days
dude vacation for two weeks five days
drink every day
okay dude i did drink every day but
those are my favorite people you're back
from cage like dude i'm done yeah and i
am and i am
i'm talking like like the sand lot type
of vibe what would we name the dog
what would we [ __ ] what's a good name
for our junkyard dog junk
junk's not bad called junk how about i
don't know but something
junk junk or just [ __ ] strider i like
word names like strider
that's gay no strider it's not a strider
it's not an airplane
what do you mean stupid strider no it's
not that's stupid just better than
junk no it's not then because people go
hey junkie and they'll they'll do do
that and then he looks like a junkie and
he rips your dick off
we feed him protein powder maybe some
steroids maybe a little bit how about uh
how about we put a nose on christian
some ears and christian you uh you
become the junk dog i'm down
hey give me a little nice bed i'll i'll
camp out here all night for you guys you
could sleep here we can set up a bed
here
how are you gonna how are you gonna
repel intruders are you gonna put you're
going to sharpen you're going to bite
their balls no he's scrappy
so you know you're going to shoot
[ __ ] pucks at him oh i could do that
i have to do that right off the [ __ ]
dome just put uh
get like fake uh teeth super sharp fake
teeth and just
i wonder if we i wonder if i could do i
wonder if the building would freak out
if i like in one of the studio space i
said like a whole bedroom like bunk beds
and [ __ ]
and just had christian and kyle sleep in
here just sleeping here
but then it would smell like [ __ ] boy
broke brokeback
podcast yeah and it's youtube at night
talking you guys are all you guys you
know what happens you guys have pringles
you're all alone and lonely it's quiet
nobody's watching
next thing you know you're like you're
feeding your feet are cold
do you do jiu jitsu i've never seen well
i don't know how to do it well here let
me show you just here turn like if i
take your back
back back ruff ruff
yeah short short king sex and the dog is
just watching
and the dog oh he is he's still dressed
up as though yeah i still have the ears
on
everything earbud over there and then
you're dressed up like a cat and you
guys play
cat no i hate cats yeah but he's chasing
the kitty around catches it
no that's got weird cat's all [ __ ]
perched up nah this got weird dude we
just oh now it's weird
is that too far it's very porn
um yeah i don't know if we could have an
animal here
no you got you can have an animal if you
bring it home [ __ ] this guy wants
a pit bull and he's like well we'll just
leave it here
no well no it's not a junkyard
office space then we could get a uh like
a snake
i was gonna say i was gonna say there
was a guy those are stupid pets
no you get a giant burmese python you
feed it rabbits
you don't tell anybody about that feeder
chickens because people are like oh
rabbits but chickens are better
chicken throw a whole chicken in there
god you tried grabbing the chicken
only grab a chicken they don't smell
they they poo it they [ __ ] everywhere
yeah yeah
but uh but this guy had his car stolen
he had a burmese pipe on his car and
the car was left in the middle of the
[ __ ] street with the doors
i don't believe that i don't either and
as you're just telling i was a god i
wish you would have ever heard that
story because it's not real
because if you've ever been around a
python i i i feel like
they're all 12 years old no they're like
yeah
and then he's driving well there are
some people that have it like we'll put
their
giant snake in the car so i can see if
somebody did
steal it they'd be like there's a
[ __ ] snake and get out but it never
happened
i've heard that story i heard the story
when i was 13 and i've held on to it
it's exactly like the story i told you
about the guy who's paddling in sharks
santa cruz
you keep writing for it huh and you keep
it's telling those stories over and over
i just believe that maybe it's possible
a shark would go i
i never happened i mean that one kid
committed uh i mean happy not here the
only kid committed suicide
by he worked at a pet shop and got all
the dangerous snakes yeah and then just
let him go in his car
yeah see that's just not a good way to
kind of a happy note
yeah joking it's not a good wedding but
the thing is is like the you think about
it it's not like those snakes are the
people people gotta realize none of
those things you let them go and they
just start [ __ ] yeah
like he was like come on oh and it was
like [ __ ]
yeah come on like you really gotta yeah
now you don't wanna do that though it
takes a long time for that poison to
work its way through your body yeah
suffering a lot of stuff maybe you pass
out if you're lucky
what's that stupid thing when they say
black mamas if you get bit by a black
mama just find a tree
and stare off into the distance because
that's the last thing you'll see
you know you're not getting you're not
getting help in time that's stupid
[ __ ] well probably not a snake dude
no don't we just get a bunch of hamsters
man
i'll just have them running around
problem with anything like that is they
[ __ ] monkeys are the worst pet
of all time yeah you got to have diapers
on them you could have and they will
bite you oh you can't have an alley you
can't have pets you shouldn't be allowed
to have them
yeah they're legal now yeah we get a
cool fish tank just for the [ __ ] of it
fishing alligator terrible idea yeah
again you gotta have
you want a piranha you can get you can
get promise of sharks no pro no part
that's stupid you ever seen
those piranhas they also don't attack
like you would think like you put your
hand in they don't go wild
that's all i used to think it was true
and then they do in the river monsters
didn't rogan you said piranhas rogan had
piranhas and he had
he had a section for goldfish and over
it said death row
and he used to put the goldfish in the
yeah it was called death row
and then he'd take the gold and then
with the piranhas just tear up that
goldfish
or was it just like no they'd eat the
[ __ ] out of it and i was like i'd be
like
i was watching that was back when we
were like in our twenties like you got
problems dude i was like you're mean
yeah that's me well you know you know
how like uh in movies like if
someone's like off the amazon wherever
they fall in the water there's a group
of piranhas
and they skin the people alive and eat
them alive that's not real i know that's
not real and i always thought it was
yeah discovery channel like solved that
problem there is
in the amazon there is that fish that
swims up your [ __ ]
he's tiny he's tiny and then he exceeds
he expands
i'd rather be bit by a shark [ __ ] man me
too i think
you know what i mean like a bull shark
you're gonna lose one of your arms
though or something
i'm here and you're going to see that
[ __ ] cat caterpillar known as the
penis fish oh come on
also also that truth it's also what jeff
bezos designed his spaceship after
have you seen that thing the dick ship
yeah i did it why not make a pony dude
why not make it like cool pointy like
you had all the money in the world
i think it just it's probably what the
science that's where they were at
they were up top they were yeah that's
where they were in the top
and then it exploded off and they came
down yeah you got to be bored
you got to be bored is this penis fish
for reals chin
it says very limited credible uh
evidence
i knew it tell i always say you're full
of [ __ ] completely i'm just saying that
i'm trying to i'm trying to dispel
all the myths you know
i'm trying to dispel all the [ __ ]
yeah i mean
who even started i'm sure it happened
once it's not like it's a [ __ ]
reoccurring problem maybe that never
happened
there's that like bacteria that anema
whatever gets in your brain
yeah that's real quick quick that's
right yeah that's right that'll get you
killed like a kid in texas
sure it'll get up your nose such and get
into your [ __ ] like bad water yeah
it's terrible
well also you get that you get that
necris you get that
flesh-eating bacteria bad situation in
still
like river water or pond water you get
they go oh we gotta start lopping hands
off [ __ ] that
those are those are the things that
they're just so many things that can
happen
out of the blue which you got to be
ready for
there's nothing you can do about it man
well somebody could break in here and
that's why we need a dog
or a jaguar you know what would be a
good pet a cheetah
no just kidding they're stupid looking
now now they're so skinny oh are you
interested i seem skinny
i love hyenas i love honestly i i i
don't know like a little foxy they have
these uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] they're
called they're like little uh little
meerkats or some [ __ ] no there's no no
yes
yeah that's awesome you should get one
of those all those things though those
things [ __ ] capture the promises
[ __ ] and i gotta hire someone to take
care of it full time it's another cost
to your boy here
yeah you guys are gonna be able to play
with it i'm the one that has to deal
with it i actually hate hyenas i think
they're the only animals that are evil
they kill each other as babies they say
they like these
bears yeah they do no lions kill babies
no i know but i'm saying
baby hyenas kill their own brothers and
sisters
when they're in a litter there's they
they literally kill each other they suck
and then they just make those weird
noises and their their genitals drag on
the ground they laugh
yeah lions hate them when when lions
kill them i'm always
i'm kind of like the vultures of the
land just wait for people to kill [ __ ]
and then they do it
yeah they're cool they'll [ __ ] up a
leopard though and they'll [ __ ] up a
lion
oh they catch a line slipping by
themselves oh yeah game on they give
them
nice you get you get a whole bunch of
bites they can they can crack hippo chin
there was that picture that dude in
india
who uh or maybe probably africa i think
of it it's africa
and he has a pet [ __ ] hyena but it
has the it has the hannibal lecter
master oh yeah yeah
oh is that real chin or yes those are
real those those are the hyena
men of nigeria you made that up no i
didn't go ahead and put it in
put it in their name their name is the
hyena men of nigeria put in hyena men
of nigeria hyena men of nigeria there
you go that's that would be one of them
that's a spotted hyena sir yeah they'll
get it to about 175. if you have any
questions about the spotted hyena please
let me know
some bigger than that we should get one
no those are simple again
dude it's the licensing thing and here's
the problem you guys are gonna play with
this thing it's gonna bite somebody's
[ __ ] face off then i'm
liabil for it you know yeah now look at
that bad boy that could be me
yeah look at all these look at that now
that'll take a bite out of you
that look at the little kid on there now
that'll be yeah but look at that [ __ ]
game of thrones mask it's wearing dude
that thing is pure chain link fence of a
you need you need you need a proper
muzzle on that bad boy
look at that i don't know why more
people don't put hyenas in rap videos
well because they're apparently the
hell's angels
in new york city had a couple hyenas in
their basement
and a cup i heard i'm not believing this
and they had and they had a
i'll tell you a whole lot so hell's
angels who want to avoid the police at
all
yep they had well they had a clubhouse
and apparently they had a couple of wild
boars down there
now hold on now here's what they used to
hold on who told the story
somebody who knew oh no somebody who
knew and what i
heard here's another story i heard
everybody hell's angels owning hyena
there was that there was a there was a
bat
there was a bet on whether or not a game
bred
pitbull how it would do against a hyena
and they and they pitted it i'm not sure
if this is the hell's angels i just
heard
and they pitted it against a
pit bull the pit bull was game as [ __ ]
and the people were scratching and they
let that pitbull go and apparently haina
looked at it
and when the pit bull came in the hyena
went i'm gonna bite you on the top of
your skull now well they have the
hardest bite
that's right so you think oh you think
you got a strong bite very cool
watch this and bit it on the head and
bit through its head and basically i do
i love you're telling this tale
and it's entertaining for us that never
happened now listen
i have it on good authority you don't
imagine hell's angels
what'd you guys get buzzed for uh do we
smuggle in these hyenas from africa man
because we want to see them entertain
the boys
well maybe they did in new york i can
see them doing that no way in the
basement in new york
yeah you gotta you got a little fighting
they're outlaws
oh [ __ ] little outlaw get a little hyena
then you have a wild boar
with a pit bull i gotta be honest man
that hell's angel life looks fun
okay not for me but it looks trivial
question who wins in a fight
donkey or hyena
god donkey donkeys are the most gangster
like animal why don't you go ahead and
put
donkey versus hyena donkeys you know
people have donkeys around like all
their horses scare off like all the
wolves
i didn't know this mm-hmm i didn't know
i learned that you said that i thought
you know
yellowstone is that true yep is that
really true
yeah go ahead and uh go ahead and take a
look at this
they look like friends oh they're
buddies
oh no no they're not no he's not no
they're not
they're not buddies
so don't [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with that does
he have his
ear yeah that's a [ __ ] hyena
okay with a very strong i don't know why
more teams and people don't use
uh donkeys as mascots they're [ __ ] i
know they look stupid
but they're so gangster man they're i
didn't know they were this gangster i
didn't either
[ __ ] yellowstone season three by the way
i don't like seeing that i didn't
realize it that bad but you know
how you know you just stunk you off and
quickly regret it he's just yanking on
his ear though
he didn't kill him okay well this one
says killed no there is
yeah dude you want you want to [ __ ]
every day sometimes i go through world
star in the morning when i'm getting my
morning news
god sometimes i show [ __ ] on there like
god i wish i didn't see that but you
can't help but click on it
yeah i don't like that [ __ ] oh it'll
ruin your [ __ ] i don't like that
stuff
you see something they didn't show the
video thank god but there was this uh
i'm sure it's not gonna event this girl
she's like uh
instagram influencer you know and she's
always taking pictures and [ __ ]
she went to this place and had like a a
waterfall
she got too close it fell off seriously
she died well she had a picture of her
like you know i'm brazil
and i've been exactly where she was at
and obviously i didn't do it
but they get on the edge of it and then
hang off and it's
oh well it's all the way up no you can't
do it it's all the way dude i was so
can't do that when i when i fought in
brazil yeah that's what we did
probably you stay far away from there
don't you from that i get to there and
that's right
i'm all easton my coach scooted on the
edge and can't do that
can't do that here's why i'm always
afraid when i see a [ __ ] ledge like
that
that a gust of wind is going to go and
then
because i was in big whiskey mountain
and
it's a huge mountain in wyoming and i
climbed to the top of that mountain
and i looked over the edge there and
there were parts where you could
well you would free fall for i don't
know a mile i don't know what the [ __ ]
it was it was just a cliff you know
and you just i lay i i crawled over on
my tummy
yeah and held on the wind was blowing
hard and i just looked over
i don't get like paralyzed with heights
but it's definitely i'm not
i'm not comfortable with it no like in
brazil i was so scared man
my thing is pros and cons pros i hang
off i get a dope picture you get a bunch
of likes that's cool
khan dude it's over pop
you take her it's so high up you won't
even see them you know it's like yeah
like wiley coyote it'd be like you don't
even see him
i like watching some of the things i
like watching sometimes like in brazil
or wherever it might be
uh somebody tries to rob the wrong
person and that person happens to have a
piece on him and he's trained world star
has that but they're not even trained
they try it's like some punk tries robin
a dude like he tried carjacking him with
a gun
this just just a dad with these these
three
black dudes rolled up on him tried
jacking his like g-wagon or something
they have the gun on his face and he
gets that car like this
and then probably been watching so much
[ __ ] john wick or something he's like
yeah
it's the gun what then picks the kid up
spikes him on his head and his buddies
just take off
and you can see him like teach him a
lesson like he obviously wasn't going to
shoot him we just teach him a lesson oh
that's crazy yeah
it's so funny he brought that up this
just happened melrose shootout
yeah so just so you guys know you know
if you don't live in l.a so melrose
there's a group of guys
that they they see you pull up to the
restaurant stuff and everyone's eating
outside right now so you pop the
restaurants and
whatever your g-wag your mercedes your
porsche's ferraris and they look at your
watches and stuff like that then they
just wait for you to leave
and then they're robbing people like all
the time all this happened in beverly
hills
that's the same group oh it's the same
group melrose beverly hills the same
group doing it
wow guys yeah let me see this pick the
wrong guy but then look what happens
when uh
at the end of it he's talking to two
girls here the state of our newsroom out
of an attempted
robbery that ended with bullets flying
this happening just after seven o'clock
last night
near melrose and white hornets standing
there talking in a parking lot when the
dodge avenger pulls up
two men get out one of them brandishing
a gun then the victim of the robbery
pulls out
himself opens fire on those would-be
robbers
and that's why you should carry kids i
agree with eggs who got out of the car
he got shot right he shot the guy in the
stomach he did he hit him but
two of them got uh gun shot and one to
the thigh and then one two three oh that
guy kept firing yeah
well so this dude's a bad [ __ ]
that's number two i just carry a gun
though
yeah but now now does he get booked for
anything that's the thing yeah i don't
know because
he had it like here yeah let me see this
again but the problem is is this kid
pulls a gun up i love this well look at
this bad [ __ ] watch this
it all depends you [ __ ] the wrong
dude this is self defense
the guy could definitely self defense
the guy gets that well if he has a
license he doesn't have a permit
even then though the
this is a great reason why you should
carry he just went whoop bang bang
wow the police later arrested the two
suspects fled on foot
fighting it far why i need
this really does make me want to carry
something on my hip
you understand correct i mean in your
car yes right now the times are wild
yeah
otherwise you're sitting down especially
where you're at on the west when i go
the west side
you got to have a piece especially at
night you must be
you must be ready at all times you guys
can probably get one easily
i mean i have i have one no no a perm i
got a problem i have permit yeah
yeah i care yeah i carry at all times oh
yeah i didn't know that
yeah i don't want to [ __ ] yeah once [ __ ]
started popping off on the west side and
me and chin had to go down there and
[ __ ] podcast and everything was
boarded up i was like god yeah
i guess dude i need my no those were
dicey times remember chin
oh we boarded up the walls i mean what's
crazy is when they looted and destroyed
everything they didn't touch
ours i like to think the looters went we
liked that guy
and they kept going it's so tempting to
our building dude
it's so exciting mirror glass all over
the place and then if they start
and if they knew anything it's like dude
there's so much there's thousands and
thousands
of elections what are you gonna do let's
let's podcast now we can podcast
no no they steal the laptop come on bro
the laptops the cameras
like this is all going for thousands of
dollars yeah
that's the move yeah they're really
[ __ ] up
no they didn't they did a good job oh
yeah thank god thanks for being fans of
the show
i did a show subscribe like i did a show
last night at the laugh factory and
it was it was the factory it was good
everyone have mascot now it's packed
and it was uh ruby tuesdays and uh
um ruben paul's [ __ ] great guy and a
great comic
and uh it was a lot of a large black
tuesday
night yeah and it was also i i followed
uh
lunell who's a legendary female comic
she's probably 70.
black comic chappelle's producing her
next special there she is she's a killer
oh she's a monster she's a killer you
would know her
if those of you guys can't see you know
her from borat
yeah yeah and when you the thing about
that now is when you when you're brian
callan and you're
following her after she's done a half
hour you understand
and it's it's an interesting experience
because
when they go you guys know him from the
goldbergs from fighter and the kid
crickets because a lot of black people
aren't watching
i mean we haven't uh maybe but then in
this particular demo
it's very interesting and uh but
that was interesting you got to have you
got to have experience
in that situation just a different vibe
not a good spot for someone who
for a novice because you gotta you gotta
you know you gotta you gotta warm up the
usual tricks don't work well it's the
same thing like when i
when i opened for miss pat and my in
miami
when i say this i was the only white guy
in the building there you go
and which i don't you know it's all good
but they're gonna they're you gotta win
them you gotta you gotta win their trust
a little bit they're gonna be like but
like this
yeah there's no time to be like hey
how's everyone what don't get up there
all right
go oh that's right but the guy her uh so
the way
miss pat does it she has this opener he
does 30 minutes
and she does an hour there's no in
between okay so he did 20
so you could tell he's like this [ __ ]
white boy taking 10 minutes of mine so
then he was like oh what's up man not
the friendliest dude
he'd his 20 and obviously crush that's
his crowd yeah and i go out
yeah it was working a little bit it's
worked it worked sometimes it'd be
working it's worked
yeah i got them i got them but i'm at
the end but it was worth it it took me
some time
peter's with me kyle peter's with me
because he's filming it's when i was
doing the logan paul
floyd fight and peter was there and he's
like man at first i thought you were
[ __ ]
for the first time i can't believe you
pulled together i'm like well that's
that's not my that's not that's not a
home game dude it's an awakening for the
first time in
many years i my first joke ate [ __ ] was
met with this
ah and i was like
whoa was there was i like it though i
like was the other who else was on
uh some some really good people i i
can't remember offhand but like you know
a lot of boys no no but a lot of bad
people a lot of really good people were
there i mean like
you know i can't remember the lineup but
it was impressive
so you know it was just like but but it
was it was a it was an interesting i
love
that sometimes i need that keep going
yeah and then i was asked actually by a
couple club owners who owned some black
clubs to come
you know do some [ __ ] which is always a
good sign but it was it was a 20 minutes
it took me some time because you know
sometimes a crowd is listening to jazz
or they're listening to rock and you
come in playing classical a lot of times
they're there to see one
person and they're just like dude just
get up where the [ __ ] the person can
just get off stage
well they're where's the headlights
that's right like they're there to see
one person and they don't like
anybody else just by default because
they're just not trying to hear you yeah
it's just like but then that's where
that's where the challenge comes in
that's how that's when you're a comic
that's yeah you got to work that's all
so speaking of which
hey guys if you like stand-up comedy you
come see me
in ontario this the end of this month
july
29th 30th 31st the inland empire and
then i'll be at the
american comedy club august 4th okay
just one night
just i'm just doing wednesday i might do
two shows
american comedy club just gonna do too i
have nothing else to do on a wednesday
i'll [ __ ] drive down there and do it
you know i'm i'm excited cause i'm
working on new [ __ ] right now i'm just
trying to work on a bunch of stuff that
i'll do a weekend at americans though i
will i've done that i've done that but
i'll just do that for now
i think yeah uh
we're um next i'm in tacoma next week
when you're in ontario i'm in tacoma
i like tacoma was that the twenty was
that chin the twenty seven twenty twenty
nine some [ __ ] like that
you know what to do got to point 29 30th
31st did you go to coeur d'alene you go
to idaho after that from there yeah
no no not tacoma spokane bubba you're
thinking okay i'm sorry same owners
though
tacoma is in washington though right uh
washington but it's outside seattle
uh-huh i've been remember spokane's more
it's like literally an out like 40
minutes from court coma
is up there and it what's the club like
it's tacoma comedy club it's same owners
of spokane county club
have you done brickstown i'm not yet
they the so the the and they own
uh tin or whatever it is but it's the
same great owners yeah the best green
rooms
they're the best yeah yep i love that
but yeah tacoma should be interesting
but it's interesting because the covid
usually and you know this but anyone
usually july
june july and august worst times to do
stand-up time because people don't want
to be indoors
right it's nice weather but because of
covet people are trapped inside forever
now for comics if you see any comic torn
they're taking a risk
because usually dry is the worst time to
sell tickets yeah so it's like well
hopefully people want to
you know go to shows because we've been
locked down that's like philly in this
time i did great in philly it was
great but i at first it took a while
because at first i was like what's going
on here because the sales weren't
usually last time i went there i was
sold out before i even
when you do philly in the summer
everybody goes down to shore
that's when you get you get out of
philly you don't stay in philly in
general most comics unless you're like a
chappelle or rogan they're not
summers are off dude it's interesting i
used to power through summers
and then i went to calgary in the summer
i haven't been back
one of my favorite clubs yuck yucks yes
i love them down with them in the summer
and they went
never been there in summer dude so
people don't go in they don't go inside
well here's the problem
is they only get a certain up there
they're only a certain amount of
daylight and only certain amount of good
weather
there it is and and then also i was
there during stampede week which is
their bit like
literally it's like and they're all it's
like dude
when i say nightmare yeah nightmare
i take all these hard work personally oh
i don't nothing depresses me more
i like that it just sucks but i get mad
at
my agents like you've been those for 30
years dude how do you not know the
stampede is there
when i'm there and how do you know that
they don't come out and what was
stampede like was it good though i hear
you
you got to come down stampede i've never
been i want to go but
but yeah like i'd want to go if i could
do shows and then go over the stampede
i'm not just going to flip the [ __ ]
calgary with stampede
no you're not going to slap just for the
time i heard it's great though yeah
people love it you and i are far apart i
like this couch though if we ever decide
to roughhouse it up a little bit you
know what i'm saying
maybe you don't want to break it though
no no no look it's me in five years
that's cool
it's a cool pillow i like that you sent
me that video of you
i'll send you almost 5 25 just keep you
in line a little bit yeah sometimes i
feel like you you forget
forget what you know how like when like
because i stopped drinking
like i feel tight and strong you've been
you haven't drank my neck up a little
bit i'm not gonna lie
your neck's always
but i like to i like to send you those
videos because you know how like when
like a twink hangs out with health
angels yeah he's like oh i'm the same i
get tatted
yeah that's what this is like on the
show really you're the twink you're mark
i'm the hell's angel
my hands are fast but what they're not
though so i'm not afraid of dead lift
what are you going to do dead lift me
you know what i'm saying that's how i
think
i've never seen you dead left i did lift
it
i did lift i flipped tires now yeah what
i dare say that my son flips tired hey
bro my technique
my technique is really really good
flipping tires well my my deadlift
technique technique is almost near
perfect to be honest with you
what do you have a duckduckgo shirt on i
don't know because i wear whatever they
give me watch this
here here i engage my [ __ ] and look
at this ready
[Music]
you don't get better than that i'd have
to see a lot of weight on there you know
you know who i send my deadlift videos
to before i post them
because all the form oh god thank you
such a [ __ ]
i'm like right unless you can dead lift
600 pounds shut the [ __ ] up
yeah because cause you were doing 525
like you were waking up in the morning
well because
uh mark harley's finally back from
[ __ ] costa rica i've been working out
by myself this
time finally he's back tan of [ __ ] you
guys see him tomorrow he's tan as [ __ ]
so he's like oh that's dead left i'm
like kelly i love dead lifting and he's
like oh you know i'm gonna go for
525. he's gonna hate him telling the
story i'm like cool man so we've warm up
and he's dude he's so much bigger than
like he's shredded dude
and he's strong he's strong on certain
things i mean
yeah so you know we're warmer and i did
like i know i said of like 315 and i was
like all right what do you want to do
man just put the 525 on let's not waste
you know energy yeah so he's like okay
he puts 525 on he goes
can you film this and you know he's like
whoa you know there's like metallica
playing he's like
literally he's like i'm like [ __ ] yeah
you see in the video i'm like let's go
mark
pr here my man he's like i got this he's
all here
i was like oh [ __ ] dude yeah and then
you just lifted it like you were waking
up
and then he goes what should we do i go
oh you can leave it and he goes you're
gonna do it
yeah i'm gonna do it man and then yeah
for whatever reason deadlift comes
naturally oh he's super strong that's
why
whatever reason is that you're bit
you're patient i've been doing since
what i've been doing since fourth grade
you you are very strong but
i don't look it um i think you do
oh really yeah i think you do i know
what you mean like if you look at
certain bodybuilders they're really like
if you looked at mark you'd like he's
stronger than him
yes his legs are bigger his body's
bigger he's just and he's like
he's like veiny but you have that weird
kind of like the tendon looks like it
attaches here
like you know yeah it's strange yeah
like if you were covered in in
fur i'd be like ah well like like there
was some guy i
i might start doing a thing on my
instagram just body of the day
jim there's i know it sounds super
chaotic there's this guy
and i looked at marketing well that
guy's the perfect body dude started
laughing dude his body's insane dude
yeah
like what the [ __ ] some guys have the
best body so i know my joke about that
i joke about that is some dudes you'll
look at some dudes and their bodies are
so good that you don't want to have sex
with them
but i just want to rub them down i
wouldn't mind rubbing them down and i
don't know i just want to literally like
if i had to rub them down or i'd be
frowning but i'd also be like behind my
face i'd be like
oh i just like damn dude yeah you're
back yeah
if nobody is looking i just want to i
don't care if they're filming it's just
goals i want goals and then
i take it in with my hands no there's
one guy there and mark's like dude his
you know his like symmetrically like his
everything's perfect like his
quads his pick you know what i'm gonna
start doing we go hey man you mind if i
take a picture you're my dime piece of
the day
this one do because they left with their
that's when they started doing this with
their shirt off
dude you don't their bodies are stupid
daddy
and they're so strong they're there with
their you know videographers filming
stuff
but i looked at my dad this [ __ ]
body's perfect there's a guy i'm gonna
get him and marco
you know mark he's so positive he goes
you can get there like but i can't dude
i personally would rather um hold on
hold on uh
oh click click click on the far up top
right one top right the boy's flexing
no there's nothing these boys are bodied
up
no none of them that guy's dying piece
though uh scroll down mm-hmm
hold on let me see no i don't care about
these no
i don't like any of their bodies i like
no no hold up
is that hold up do you see the guy uh go
see
in the middle there this one or this one
the that one
that guy's good is that him that's him
that's mr dime piece
yeah that's a good body but when you do
bubba i gotta be honest with you like i
i he's probably like he's like by 510
too
bodied no no that's bought it up but i i
prefer an
athlete's body like i can tell that's
like your sport your body comes more
from sports
wrestling and fighting there's something
a little bit more um
cat what's more attractive that or like
athletic build
thick athletes like brendan or like
thick athletic build or dime piece gym
guy
for me personally yes i like a guy who's
kind of bulky but with a little bit of
fat
like i know he isn't strict so i know i
can't eat out with him there you go
that's more attractive most women do so
i'm here to say most women do because
that looks like i feel like guys like
that do it for other guys
yeah there's also yes there's a there's
a thing going but it's working
it works cause i see him in the gym like
god dawg he takes shirt off like that
[ __ ] no no it's very
amount of work but i know some people
are like oh just stare at something
dude dude take all steroids you want
you're not going to look like that takes
a lot of work there's another guy though
too today i was like god
dog yeah yeah but i i think i'd rather
have i've showed that little guy tristan
right there on the right
he's like 19. all-natural that's not
natural he's natural
well look at this picture of him i know
that's why i'm
yeah you can google him when he was 12
dude i've seen him when he was 12 and i
know exactly who that is
and uh okay maybe he is natural
i don't believe that i don't believe i
do just because he's so there's no way
someone's given a 12 year old steroids
like that no but i don't
but i still think i mean i don't know
but and i don't care but that's that
dime piece again dude
yeah he's distracting i like his face i
love women no no
i don't know what's going on dude i like
his face i'm very happy with his
whole outfit too yeah that's the thing
at zoo culture you know how like some
gyms you just you put on some shorts and
a [ __ ]
tee and go to work sure dude people are
in fits
yeah well that's a whole fit yeah
there's everything is considered there
the tank top where it was cut
everyone talked with hats like that yeah
and that tank top we used to be a
t-shirt or it was already a tank top and
he said this tank top
needs to be a little more of a tank top
why would you cover them guns up right
i got it and you got to see a little
side boob license to [ __ ] conceal
there man
it's just it's just it's just all about
being a peacock i'm very happy with the
baseball
i could never get there that's not like
my body's just not i don't think you i
don't think so
but i oh dude i would love that really i
mean it would go too yeah if you have
some bodies
go terrible on stage for me but no i
like uh
there he is yeah see i like that you're
what are we doing
what are we doing is he built like a
ninja turtle dude he is the same body as
a ninja
don't show that other day i don't care
about that stuff you yeah you're
interesting because
there are some crossfit dudes that have
bodies that i i'm i'm all about but well
he's built like the crossfit
a little bit if you see the crops going
down bring up some of these crosstalk
let me see who else is on there oh
there's a whole page this looks too much
bodybuilderish you understand
i want i want i want
there's one guy this is a bodybuilding
gym clearly
oh dude like i'm the most out of shape
guy there yeah
this is this is where people's job is to
do this no not him
but i like i like a i like more of uh
you know i don't know
you know who's got a great body [ __ ]
mark has a good body
uh sage north cut or something like that
have you seen him lately
no oh my god he looks crazy right now
crazy in shape
like just he almost looks like he's
actually doing roids now which before
because he's been lifting all his life
right yeah but he's natural like he
looks big now
he's yeah he's just yes that says bravo
like it's so easy for building oh
steroids just like
man i know some guys who are oh dude
wait you can see he's just a lot bulkier
like bigger he's also growing up too
that's the other thing yeah let me see
the girl
says woman can you guess which ones ate
the turkey leg
now hold on let me yeah he he he he's
not he's winning anymore he's the yeah
he is how dare you
won championship he hasn't gone well for
him over there they've given
terrible matchups yeah who's working out
today
he's young you know smart kid too i
think he's getting an
engineering degree from uh uh texas a m
yeah if anybody can pull it off
he can you know what he is he's he's
basically i mean he has a he has to get
to a certain level of success to even be
compared to him i'm just saying with his
religion and his body he's very similar
to tim tebow oh is that right yes
okay i'm gonna put you on a spot brandon
i'm gonna put you on the spot
what all due respect easy now i don't
get in trouble here i know
i got a gun to your head okay is that
natty
all right that's all i need to hear it's
all right because i saw you do this
your face went like this it's tough
right it's fine
i don't know i don't know and the
organization he's fighting is pretty
loosey
yeah does he feel does he feel a little
too muscular for
i'm surprised he's so muscular i like
that bicep the only problem is he's a
very muscular guy naturally
that's him years ago yeah he was younger
and that was when he was younger so it's
not
inconceivable to think that this guy
he's getting older i don't assume he's
on it it's
tough dude because that's thing like tim
tebow klopp like the i i do know
freaks i agree lawrence vickers and he
is kind of a freak he is so so if
anybody's natural
who looks like he's and also but also
his dad was like a bodybuilder
also got in trouble for his own steroids
i think
i i i don't care if either way i think
that he
he's a guy you know what he's a guy
who's so naturally muscular
that it wouldn't it wouldn't surprise me
if he was natural that's what i'm saying
i'm gonna go ahead and assume he's
natural because i hate when people just
assume we can go ahead and be diplomatic
and say that
this is april that's him in april
and then i have plenty more dates doing
natty or not that's what i want him to
do place more dates sage north
please i love him there's nobody better
in the business to break it down he'll
know
who knows what's that this guy named uh
what's his name it's plates more dates
but he does natty or not
yeah like he'll do he'll follow john for
years and
break down fight by like he's a beast
with it okay this guy we've had him on
the uh
we've pulled him up before yeah more
plates
more dates do sage north cut dude
please yeah he's [ __ ] great
yeah do you know who had on food truck
yesterday didn't come out the next week
but brandon moreno
you know who that is i sure do the
flyweight champion of the world the
first
mexican champion dude when they say he's
the nicest kid in the world
he is the nicest guy of all time he's so
[ __ ] friendly really
him and wonder boy they they uh we're
talking like who's who's nicer like
they're both so [ __ ] friends yeah
he's so friendly gilbert burns too is a
very sweet gilbert's very nice train
with gilbert
very nice yeah gilbert's very very but
brandon moreno is the nice guy in the
world
is that right he's my girl's favorite
fighter because he's my skin yeah so i
haven't sent her a video he sent her
this long video in spanish
i think he's solar i don't know what
he's saying
yeah the nicest [ __ ] kid though what
if i fought a
killer too fought a killer
dominated the killer dominant that's
what's crazy but that's why he said like
i was like oh
are you gonna rematch figarito and he
goes don't make if they want to do that
i guess but that makes sense to me he's
like if it was like a close fight i'd be
down but yeah i completely dominated
dude
two rounds yes he's like there's not
much left for me to do with him
so he talked about finding cody
garbrandt oh
cody's got 35 no no no cody's going down
20. cody can suck down
25. cody's small dude he can suck down
to 25 how tall is he
short 25 is easy for him is that right
yeah i just had him on my shoulders wow
i thought cody was a lot bigger than
that cody like an inch or two taller
than me
maybe maybe an inch taller than you he's
a small guy oh wow 25 is going to be
perfect for him
oh i did not but he he uh sugar shots
not five eight not five eight
but it's he says tj's five six tj is
taller than him by probably two to three
inches
that then then cody yeah tj's way way
bigger
wow okay yeah tj's now everybody should
keep keep henry cejudo in retirement
because nobody wants henry cejudo
at 125. nobody wants him not a good idea
let's just keep him in retirement
because if henry decides to come back
i'm never betting against henry though
he's been
are you do you have can we talk for a
second about um
just real quick about what you think
between cory
san hagen and because that's one of
that's christian allen's disciple then
you got the great tj dillashaw they're
both
under christian for a while they both
used to train together like they're
they're close
wow yeah you want are they close they
because they
used to be yeah well corey was young he
was probably 16 when when
no corey started 16 when he's with me
okay you're talking
about that no three years ago they were
trained four years wow
um that dude is story
yeah monster yeah
that's a i mean it's crazy i'm not gonna
pick cause both of them are
close friends okay so like it's a crazy
thing to throw
tj in there after three years i feel
like two years
after two years it's still a long time
um
you know if anybody has the strong
enough mind it's tj he's just a champion
he's amazing
and it's very very very hard to bet
against him um
now let me caveat with this so tj asked
for this fight by the way
tj do you think it's an easy fight he
thinks they want the ufc
because that's uh we're not i have my
food truck last week
it's it's available now and he said he
go and i go dude that's why
i said do you have two year layoff like
why not come back maybe fight a top 10
guy let me tune
up and he he's like oh i don't want to
tune up he goes they were going to give
me a title shot right away i was
supposed to fight the winner of
peter john sterling because he left as
the champ he lost that 125 didn't lose 0
135 no he didn't
so he left as a champ and he was like
dude so they're just gonna give me a
title shot against petey on
alger maine but obviously the legal knee
they got a rematch i'm not gonna wait
for that
so i want the next best best thing cory
say
santa hagan's a good fight for me well
he's also
like people are talking about san diego
after he knocked out frankie edgar that
way and everything else
marlon mariah i mean he's lost algebra
he's [ __ ] unbelievable did he lose
algerman yeah i got
choked out in a minute oh jesus um here
here's the other thing you gotta worry
and again i love cory saying hey he gave
him his nickname the same man he's an
aurora
kid yeah i love cory yeah that's my guy
their team just saw him
love them i got you the thing you got to
worry about betting on this fight
is corey has been taking down every
single ufc fight he's been beside
frankie edgar because he knocked him out
in 30 seconds
so his wrestling is not his forte it is
it is not his forte
wrestling is tj's forte it's his fortune
to think about i am thinking about that
and here's the other thing corey's never
been past the third round
tj [ __ ] the only thing i would say is
that strives on the fourth of july tj
tj uh having having been next to these
guys and
you know knowing tj the size difference
to me seems palpable it's a it's it and
again it's not the end all and be all
but but cory it could fight
easily at 45 that's more his weight i
think
no i think so he's pretty big dude he's
the the skinny but he's not strong
enough no those boys are strong man
maybe if like a super fight maybe rumor
he's young dude
he's young the only reason like i'm not
rooting against court never rooting
against [ __ ] corey sanhagen
he's young so he's going to be your
champ he has a lot of years to go
for tj dude there's so many naysayers
it's like oh just because of steroids
stop with that they tested all his
previous urine samples
if you if you know tj he took he took
that because he's cutting 125.
he thousand easier cut tj is not a small
guy it was a
nightmare he never should have done
he'll admit that he said i should have
done it i thought i could do it because
mentally i figure i can do anything it
was a [ __ ] nightmare i took
epo to get through that awful idea
[ __ ] up
but it's like you know tj's a [ __ ]
beast he's one of those guys tj he's one
of those dudes but here well
what i was saying is for tj there's so
much more pressure on him
cory's gonna be fine no matter what
happens saturday night for tj's knife if
tj loses this
yeah at he's 33 yeah like you you we got
to get going
well when i saw him he looks awful i saw
him one time he looks like he looks like
the kind of junkyard dog i want for this
[ __ ] studio
that is as close to a human pitbull as
you get look at that [ __ ]
sucking weight he's such a badass but i
he's built like a
man i saw him backstage right before he
went to fight
um uh the second time he was gonna fight
uh
the great brazilian who held the title
for a long time the [ __ ] was his name
i'm sorry jose aldo no the the brazilian
who held the title at 135 i think for a
long time
uh he was out of aldo's
starts with a b henna bra yeah
i'm when i tell you when i [ __ ] tell
you he was
walking around with his group like he tj
had just won the fight and i talked to
him about that and and the [ __ ]
was like i'm
more relaxed when it when it's game time
when it's show time
it works that's when that's when he
comes along a lot of people
yeah that's when he thrives that's when
he's actually at his best and so there's
a reason he's a champion he's made that
walk
and that's a huge thing when you're when
you're that great look at dominic
cruz who came back after that long
layoff and was a world beater
and and and looked unbelievable i think
you'll see the same thing yeah molly
caveat with with this is you know
corey's young he's never been those
championship rounds
[ __ ] dog there's a lot of pressure on
him there's so many naysayers
yeah but he'll be tough it'd be tough to
bet against tj i wouldn't bet against
him i'm not betting on this one
you're not no i love both guys
i'm i guess what's the odds right now
chin go to draftkings
hold up a little random but do you think
cody
and tj will fight again or no yes you do
you do
well uh i think it's so decisive twice
it just depends yeah because i know tj
won both
fights so knockouts yeah it's just
depends it depends what cody wants to do
so if cody fights sugar
135 just to get out of the way for
because he's one fight away from a title
shot he said
so if he does that and then goes to 125
yeah
yeah he just lost his he just lost
pretty decisively
yeah yeah he's down to 25. he's cody
cartwright former world champion
yeah he's a monster yeah he had a huge
win before that
decisively oh yeah 100 million that's
why we're talking about so cody's gonna
fight at 125.
one time so he's gonna fight sugar shawn
at 135. this is the plan i think
you can fight show your shot at 135.
pretty good fight for cody
not the great i mean sugar's a [ __ ]
badass he's a badass
i mean he looks i know he was fighting a
guy who wasn't shouldn't have been in
there against him but
sugar shawn is a [ __ ] man cody
had finished that guy cody hits like a
[ __ ] yeah
yeah but but sugar shawn is just so
tanky
i can't believe he's not ranked it's
hilarious he's a top five
that's aggressive yeah is it yeah we
well we
we all love sugar charming i love it i
just talked to yesterday yeah i love
them you got your top five super
aggressive you got
t.j dillashaw it's a stacked weight it's
such a stack thing to say top five
you've got peter yanus
he's not ranked al jermaine sterling you
got peter yan you got corey sandhigh and
you got
jose cody aldo marlo morris frankie
edgar
i would put i would put him between i
put him like eight nine or ten he's new
blood he's new blood and he's young and
i just think he's
difficult to train for but this is this
is why we're on the fight campaign when
he got called out
cody's i'm not fighting that [ __ ]
schmuck he doesn't deserve he's not even
top 15 he hasn't beat anybody which is
true
but i'm like dude as far as like fame
level
like correct he's number one he's more
famous than anybody in division [ __ ]
yeah
like on twitch and being relevant and
yes like
the rain like the rankings kind of [ __ ]
things up because
now guys can go well i'm four that guy's
seven i'm not fighting him yeah when
before the rankings you
you would have to fight you couldn't
just say no he's seven i'm four this
doesn't make sense
right before you'd have to fight because
there's none of that yes so now that
they have rankings
i i get what cody's saying but it's like
dude i know he's not ranked but also
what what are rankings like think about
the people that do the rankings
exactly that's the end all be all right
like we know sugar shawn's a top ten top
we all want to see i want to see if
sugar shawn
we all want to see that fight we want to
see him fight a real uh they going to do
this
don't say a real guy because he fought
cheeto no i know people are saying well
he hasn't fought enough people okay
that the point is i want to see him
fight somebody like that yeah but here's
the other
i still got him but here's the other
over who i got him over
cody that's good really it's a very good
fight it's a good fight i think
sugar would be sugar uh on the on the uh
odds would be the underdog in that fight
he's so long he's so tall
he's my height he's 511. every bit of
511. and
i may be dumb for saying this but i
think i have cody in that fight because
in my opinion sugar can even finish that
guy in his first
ufc debut like granted that kid is a
[ __ ] monster like he took everything
he had on him cody put that kid down
exactly because cody has a lot of power
cody hits like a mac truck
yeah against smaller guys cody
yeah no he's fighting the same guy sugar
is that 35 higher level guys
i got sugar like if you can't say he's
knocked smaller guys out
wow weight division i'm what i'm saying
yeah that don't make sense
sugar couldn't knock out a guy in his
first ufc ufc
debut cody's knocked out some of the
best fighters in his wake
but here's the problem with that doug is
like
i think sugar's a top 10 guy yeah we all
think he's top 10 guy
but you gotta realize sugar's young in
his career just because he's this
famous doesn't mean he should be
fighting top five guys you actually do
him a disservice by saying
he needs to fight top five guy because
it's a marathon not a sprint
so let's say he's not ready and he
fights
cody's five or he fights those top guys
and loses
dude it [ __ ] a guy's cr career and the
fan base goes yeah he's not as good
that's true and then it gets in his head
and then
it [ __ ] you know he he he could be
their next conor mcgregor yep
yeah meaning a huge pay-per-view star so
to me
what the ufc is doing with him is
perfect and he uh he keeps asking for
top five
champions and the ufc is like calm down
young man just looking great he looked
great
notice they never do that with anybody
else everybody else is [ __ ] dude you
get thrown to the goddamn
sharks yeah but with sugar they're like
no no let's take it slowly they do it
with mark
and i and i love it and well marlon you
got marlin
the uh who's the guy who was a taekwondo
guy who fought frankie edgar
they gave him frankie edgar and you were
like rodriguez
yeah and you were like don't give him
the [ __ ] frankie he's not ready for
that
even frankie said that it changed it
[ __ ] his whole career
chemistry of his brain i mean he's kind
of coming back that kind of he's never
been the same you said i was like why
you had this exciting [ __ ] this
young exciting
they do it all the time except with
sugar shawn
well it's maybe they're learning you
know
there's something going on there i love
it who's the other guy
you and i like can we get me whiter like
can i get as white as biden
with this lighting you guys have the
same hair so i look like casper the
angry ghost right now that's your skin
bubba
no i have beautiful skin dude and i'm
tan hey chin who's the guy we like he
blew out he's brazilian blue on his
[ __ ] shoulder doing the worm
the catapult johnny walktop johnny
walker you about johnny walker
dude knocked right he was like that
we're like man him versus john this is
the fight
they catapult him to the top he knocked
the dude out he's like in brazil is like
yeah
does the worm boom blows his shoulder
out
has never been the same since god damn
it you can't do those things man
you got to be careful i've always
wondered how many how many football
players get injured
after the celebration people jump out a
ton
to tj dale shots plus 175.
let's say i didn't know either of them
i'd put money on tj at plus 175
you would yes he just with his
experience
another two year layoff
if i want to make money like the reason
your bet is to make money not because of
your friends so if you want to make
money
you know you put you put 100 on tj you
win 175.
i'm you put a grand on you're making
good
yeah no i'm just saying so it's good to
know
it's it's it's not about like because
you want to make money so if you're in
about on
corey it's like you know unless you're
like floyd you're betting like ten
thousand to make
you know even you bet ten thousand and
two thousand yeah it's not great yeah
it's not
and it's not taking a risk the biggest
risk yeah dude you've got
a thousand to one plus one twenty
seventy five
it's not bad and then i i don't know
what the odds are for the over under on
rounds but
if you think tj's gonna win it's gonna
be tj i think decision
so you do tj to win parlay it with via
decision now you're making money
are you gonna see some takedowns in this
fight you think
unless cory can knock him out early with
his knees you're gonna see a lot of
times
you can see a lot of takedowns oh why
you asked because tj's been sleeping at
least your bowling
gym his wrestling gym this sounds much
of a savage
tj's listen when people go oh this guy's
the you know has the kobe mentality this
guy's just like kobe
tj the closest thing we have to kobe
bryant in the ufc i've heard this
i've heard he's so competitive you don't
take him down he has no friends
he has no friends we talk about on the
show he's like and i go dude most people
consider an [ __ ] he's like yeah i'm
not trying to make friends man
he's like i i pride myself on that like
i'm there to do work i'm depressed
so dude this is his schedule trains
in orange county where where the [ __ ]
he's training monday through thursday
thursday
night flies out to colorado sleeps
at the in the wrestling room they have
like these little bunk beds there has to
be help
he's just he's a dog [ __ ] spark
sleeps
in the bunk bed so at night he goes i
can't sleep i just drill oh
gotta get bet against that guy even
though it's our boy my my listen i
understand boy is my brother aurora
aurora should move that gym here so that
he can train at night here
yeah wow do they have it for the rounds
yet tin
i don't know where to find that one the
round stuff that's someone said to
before so you don't think that corey is
going to go into his tr uh
going to his camp working on his
takedown defense knowing that no he can
go ahead
go ahead and do it every guy did that
against khabib every guy did that
against curtis blades
every guy did against cain velazquez you
don't have enough time there's not
enough hours in the day
to make up from tj's pedigree being an
all-american
at fullerton college wrestling and
wrestling in high school corey didn't
wrestle in high school
so he didn't have that base so it's like
you like with greg hardy
i like the guy i'm always excited same
fight there's not enough hours in the
day for him to get the tools
to be a successful heavyweight to
compete with the top guys
because curtis blade's national champion
juco he was a national champion
yeah big big superstar yeah
ridiculous but it's like striking like
all right i guess you want to fight
rosenstroke he's been striking since he
was eight dude
i know you're in the gym there's not
there's not enough hours in the day for
you to make up
yeah over the time
it's tough dude you know that's that's
what's funny about khabib it's like
you're gonna get put on your back
regardless because you can't be careful
with those transitions
when you like he goes to for one thing
and then you counter that he's just
ahead of you
you're you can't keep up well he has 25
ways to take you down yeah
you're working on five ways to defend
the takedown
then you can never make up for it yeah i
feel like
whatever you do he has seen since he was
four years old
i feel that what would have happened i
think with like connor it's like
yeah makchev who is basically his
brother they've been trained together
they say he's a better striker
so this is my thing with mike jeff this
time on the show so
better striker and i talked josh
thompson who trained with both
better striker better submissions and
then obviously his wrestling he's better
than anybody in the
in the [ __ ] division he's not
khabib's level of wrestling but who is
but he's if khabib's a 10 he's a nine
and a half
but but everything else is i hear he's
every bit as good in in in wrestling and
take down not as khabib but he's up
there i think his submissions are better
you we should probably just send the
championship belt
that's why i said get used to it but
jeff i don't know who the [ __ ] you can
but get used to him
saying that name at least it's not as
far as khabib's last name but yeah
you you saying akita but with mock jeff
too it's like
you know he's 20 and one who beat him i
forget but he's 21.
um that that was his first main event
looked a little nervous didn't perform
like you should especially the first
round look really nervous
but that's only get better but again
with ufc you don't want to toss some
[ __ ] channel or something right now
he's not ready for that no you don't
want to toss some channels just because
champions no he just needs to get used
to that pressure
it's just do when your main event five
rounds different animals
do all the press you're dealing with
real savages yeah michael chandler's
been there he's fought for the title
yeah that's true so you but you give him
an rda what do you ask for give him an
rda
on a pay-per-view give him an id you
know what you do to rda
what he wants huh yeah dude he's a
[ __ ] nightmare yeah that's that's
what's again those guys don't like
there's a lot of hours in the day to
make up to catch up you can tell that
like
it's interesting right i think that the
conner if conor hadn't broken his leg
and this is a big if but
i was really looking forward to seeing
what happened i believe that what you
would have seen
is you would have seen dustin have conor
on his back
through the whole fight i think you
would have seen that over and over again
and
to your to your point that was his
original game plan going the first it
was okay
i'm sorry the second fight when he beat
him in january yeah the plan was for
takedowns
but then he was throwing light kicks
he's like he's not checking these so
he's like i'm just keep doing these
light kicks
team was like just do like but their
entire game game plan going in
yeah wear them out and then stand up
with them third fourth and fifth
because conor's only good in the first
and second if you were if you were uh tj
dillashaw's coach would you tell him to
do the same
thing you can't rush in because cory's
knees got those crazy knees
but yes we're gonna and the other thing
it you know corey's advan this way
i wouldn't bet on the fight corey's
advantage is in the clinch too he's very
good in the clinch because of christian
allen
his knees and elbows in the clinch he's
a problem and he's the bigger guy so the
stuff like that he's a nightmare but
also now to that point
if you're gonna get in the clinch now
you're close no tj can get his hands on
you yeah but is tj is a folk wrestler
tj's not
he's a freestyle wrestler okay but but
there's
but freestyle isn't as as upper body
clench
throw heavy you don't think they know
that stuff as you don't think correct tj
knows that stuff
he may know that but i don't think
that's where his pedigree came from it
was more double since singles arm drags
that stuff right but i'll tell you this
against corey sanahan who has no
background in wrestling he's going to
look like a greco world champion
those guys don't greco you know all that
stuff
but he but he just needs to get under
hook and then heavy on the head you know
he can get to the legs yeah freestyle
you can you know he's gonna just take it
he's gonna get that leg it's such a good
fight rest cards trash but the rest of
the that's the one
yeah i i was like but i i love that yeah
my girl we had uh
we basically had this blind date with
these other parents because tiger's best
friend is this little kid from england
so we had this blind date dad blind date
so they came over to see if we're cool
so they they want to do a date night on
saturday night my god it's corey saying
tj man
literally any other night i'm down to do
but i'm not missing this [ __ ] fight
i guess she's like just recording like i
can't is this is it espn
uh plus or is this it'd be on espn
okay you don't have the app do you i do
have the app
yeah yeah man i [ __ ] do dude i don't
know i don't like you
acting like i'm so old i don't even know
what the [ __ ] app is i don't know you
know
usually you and chappelle are like what
no i didn't know what i know about this
no don't say that don't say just no [ __ ]
just know dude when i say chappelle
and what i was having a conversation
with mark and i know chappelle's gonna
watch this
but it's like your job as a podcaster is
to know what's going on in the world
that's what we do
and have an opinion on it and then you
have an opinion i have opinion and that
makes content for the show yes
but if i but if you don't know what's
going on yeah
and then i have to tell you the viewers
are more like me and know what's going
on
so they're like dude yeah we know
biden's president brent you know or we
know
that so you know you gotta have it i
need you to have an opinion
got it gotta have a current culture
whether it's pop culture
well you and i have talked about that
you and i i've always talked about like
podcasting is you gotta have strong
points of view on the world
you can you can't be lukewarm and not be
like oh really no
you've always had that you know that
it's always just a point of view better
worse
for better or worse it's way more
interesting to listen to a strong point
of view let me see
the rest of that card chin
that's when lads always great to watch
don't know these guys
i want to see uriah hall and uh uh
[ __ ]
miranda maverick she's a diamond mickey
mickey gall jordan williams those are
good fights what do you think
of uh what about the hall uh what's his
name fight
niye or nay brendan allen's great great
name as well
who is hall fighting hall is fighting
isn't hall fighting um
here sean strickland what's a good fight
the guy that had his arm jacked up by
that
jiu-jitsu guy you see that video the guy
he's fighting the guy's a world champion
juice again it's a dirty move where you
snap
you know so if you go to grab me yeah
here if you go to grab me and he's doing
this oh
god i hate that that's a tyson thing
that he did that oh that hurts he's
doing this yeah
it's just like you just pull your it's
just a dick move especially for a guy
getting ready for a fight dude
and he was doing that when they were
practicing or well he doesn't
and pops the elbow and strickland goes
what the [ __ ] is spinning oh i remember
this it hits him i remember this
and then the whole mma community was
like is that was that the right thing to
do i'm like
yeah i think so like dude what the [ __ ]
you're doing guys yeah like
what are you doing and he's also a world
like he's a big dude compete at absolute
you know super heavyweight the the guy
who did that world champion did you
support
his world champion yeah monster i could
see it you don't want those problems
no but also be careful but that's also
why i watched you you're my teammate
when sean strickland hit him
and he's like what and started walking
towards him doesn't end well for sean
strickland
it doesn't no like it's going to get his
hands on him he's like a thick
bow constrictor the thickest bow
constrictor yeah okay he's not keto you
know
davidoff is training with uh uh
marcelo garcia oh really in new york
yeah it's great and
but he was just like if you saw marcelo
just walking down the street
he is the least threatening looking guy
and yet if he grabs a hold of you
we'll see you later well it's like when
those guys tried to rob ends with gracie
and he did you know about this so he's
walking in new york you know new york
he's walking in new york this is
probably
two years ago at least he's walking in
new york and these guys are following
him and henzo gets out his phone and i
think he's on instagram live
he's like these these guys they don't
they don't know he's like watch this
so they come up to him and they're like
talking [ __ ] to him like they're trying
to rob him
so he films he beats the [ __ ] out of all
three of them and his hands are all
bloody
is that on is that on i've never seen
that yeah
yeah that that that all the guys to rob
pennsylvania that's so funny i thought
joe schilling thing looks like it's
it's a staged movie it's definitely not
i know
he's in litigation yeah what did you say
to me you can't hear what the guy says
but obviously
the guy was talking [ __ ] to him all
night he was talking [ __ ] to him yeah
staring at him talking [ __ ] to him yeah
that's such a bad
well what i said like yeah i don't know
guys the guy's suing him but it's like
and
obviously the the rules are set up for
that guy to be protected that's a pc
that has a piece of [ __ ] but that's like
sticking your hand in a [ __ ] cobra
bag and then you bit by the cobra i'm
like what the [ __ ] killing the cobra
yeah
dude you're the one that [ __ ] with the
cobra take some responsibility
yeah like that's joe schilling dude
correct and i know you don't know who he
is but then don't act like a dick
because this is why you shouldn't act
like a dick
yeah because there's a lot of guy like
joe schilling out there
i love it what's this that's him live
tweeting what that
that fight that he had oh henzo yeah
i realized how slow i was fighting
they're coming closer at some more
cigarette
can't help but have a smile on my face i
don't smoke pretend to wobble they smile
my hands hurt can't help but look at him
other one took off running he just beat
the shadow
man trying to um you know what i can't
do anymore
get out of my car and just start running
got to warm the old feet up
you would you have planner just old old
old uh achilles old band
an old band there's just old bands down
there achilles like jerky
yeah quit drinking though i said that
right
yeah it's gonna last uh who knows i mean
why though don't you enjoy
wine not anymore yeah you do you love
wine no because when i don't drink i
sleep all the way through the night
look how young i look
i gotta pee so bad you do yeah go pee
we'll take a break let's take a little
break
pay some bills y'all you know what some
things are just better at home
we like to sleep on our beds at home i
like to watch movies at home instead of
the theater
i like to chill at the crib like eat my
food at home
and now sometimes i like to work out at
home and that's where peloton comes in
you can do everything from home
everything what do you want to do man we
got you with pelton
you'll have a workout experience like no
other without ever leaving
the crib alright you don't have to do
anything man
you can just go at the crib they've
curated music they have
dope uh instructors so my favorites are
always on there
they have weights for you there's
hip-hop music country music whatever it
is peloton bike has the right music to
keep you entertained
and motivated all year long right from
the comfort of your home
it's a great workout you can do 20
minute workout 30 minute workout
45 60 minutes we got you covered man
burn some calories whatever it is man
whatever your fitness goal is
peloton bike got you covered man they
have the total
body workout experience you can choose
from cardio strength training
yoga pilates running even meditation
and they got a lot of other stuff for
you all right so with the peloton bike
there's nothing like working out from
the crib
learn more at onepeleton.com new members
can try peloton classes
for free for 30 days at one peloton dot
com slash app
terms apply that's one peloton.com
o n e p e l o t o n dot com
one peloton well we're back we're back
after a nice little peeping you take a
hard piss
i pissed hard i drink all the fluids
i do i'm never dehydrated no me neither
uh-uh
my kids don't drink enough water i'm a
bit of a nazi when it comes to food
my daughter will just like like you know
cinnamon buns
and goldfish for breakfast if i don't
watch kids though i know
dad it's summer i'm watching cartoons
yeah i make crepes i got a little secret
i put like seven eggs in the crepes and
they don't know
so it's like basically would they put
nutella in them i put a little
i'd put butter in a little real maple
syrup there's nothing like it oh i love
that
the real canadian i mean and i can make
a nectar from the trees up there man
i'll suck it straight from the tree and
vermont too
i spent a lot of time yeah i like the
vermont i like that real made the dark
and
tap that they tap that bark they tap
that i would suck a tree
i'll suck the tree off well i think you
gotta cook it
now you see it with a pocket you could
suck it straight through i don't know
you could suck the
teeth of a cow yeah but i don't but i
think if you suck the sap
it ain't as sweet i bet it's sweet daddy
i don't know about that
yeah it's like honey dude yeah it's
honey for trees can you suck the sap
because you can exactly
you can eat you can eat straight honey
from the bees i mean good luck getting
in there yeah good luck you got to smoke
them you smoke them get them tired
you smoke them out not raw but use draw
cooking coming from maple syrup heat
reduced it's a great source magnet
there you go all right yeah all i want
to know is can i suck it
let's go to maple trader okay am i
allowed to suck trees
yeah other guys are into this hopefully
i'll deep throat the shot of that branch
dude yeah get the nectar out
you got to get it from the uh no i'm
sure it's better i'm just saying can i
suck it dude gotta boil it down bro
no i'm sure it's like it's it's like
runnier but is it thick out of the tree
that thick nectar there's some things
you gotta like cassava if you eat it raw
you it's it you'll get
you'll die sometimes it's poisonous you
gotta process it
yeah so can i not suck it chin it says
no
to put on pancakes dude i'm just talking
i'm in the [ __ ]
outdoors i need some nutrition i need
some sugar to keep my height going
can i find a tree and suck it off
i don't like what you're talking ooh the
sugar maple is famous for the loosely
sweet you can make from the sap but if
you are aware that many species of
larger milk trees can also be tapped for
the edible sap
these are peoples and finer strength the
fresh sap from maple syrup there you go
that's what i'm talking about as a
refreshing drink and look at the look of
the [ __ ]
look at that thing i'll suck that up
look at that that sweet sap from the
sugar maybe oh dude i'll take it
straight to the head i'd be all over
that mm-hmm
you're in the woods and you're like
whoops some of that fell on my dong
you know what i mean that looks nice
dude just guzzling that thick
sweet nectar out of the tree all right
man
there you go oh dude look at that little
dude
that thing has a [ __ ] thing on it
what is that sap there blood
the hidden life of trees trees um some
trees like the birch trees i think it's
birch
will poison the ground so no other
[ __ ] animals
uh i mean no other trees grow yeah so
they just and then they have roots they
have these roots that connect with
uh like fungi like mushrooms under the
ground
so they have these networks where they
talk to each other it's [ __ ] crazy
there's a book called the secret life of
trees have i read it boring
i was saying like boring some people who
know the difference between trees
is that a birch hey man hey unless
you're an arborist
get out of here what you do we'll do get
the [ __ ] when we were in cleveland we
had this airbnb in like the straight
suburbs yeah were you with us think i
don't know
and we were walking and there's just two
gay
older men every day every morning for
hours
on their porch with the [ __ ] the
birds staring at birds looking for birds
are your fellas you see that i forget
what it is just look at your normal
northeastern swallow yeah you boys get
too much time in here you got a little
too much time don't you guys go [ __ ]
each other huh no come on man that's
what
that's what i said to him dude it's not
about sometimes you want to you have a
refined taste and you want to watch
birds they probably suck each other off
and stare at birds
i don't know about that i think they
just watch birds
it's just you know some people are just
into the refined
kind of pleasures i get it of life okay
it's a slower life
it's a slower life i mean if you know
what you're looking at maybe uh
my dad got into it he did he died he had
a whole bunch of your dad's a gentleman
yeah had a whole book he did you strand
me nuts watching birds
had the little binoculars i you know
okay how would you go kick that bag over
there i can't
have you ever tried to meditate in
earnest oh yeah when i was fighting i
used to do it all the time you did oh
yeah how long would you meditate for
30 minutes probably and you you'd
visualize yeah professionally not easy
though huh
i mean if you it's just like anything
you practice you're doing it for a
reason yeah
you don't do it but just to do it you
know like was it like what i mean tony
robbins like everyone
shut up yeah i'm waking up my kids like
dad let's go i'm making food
i gotta get to the gym yeah and i'm not
meditating i don't have time
writing i feel is a bit of a meditation
but yeah but anybody who's like as soon
as i wake up i sit down
you know you don't have kids if you do
you're just a bad dad my kid's hungry
right away we gotta get going yeah we
gotta get
[ __ ] to do yeah i can't and when i'm in
my car if i think about so much turn the
the [ __ ] radio down just drive inside
supposed to be able to observe
your um body yeah like your emotions and
your thoughts
and then just not be attached to them i
understand
but sometimes i want to be attached
sometimes i want to feel
anybody who has they can wake up like
the guys that meditate for an hour in
the morning
well you know um i had a tough year i
don't know if you know this but um
well he did yeah well mine was easy when
he left me for a year yeah yeah
and my mother would always say you
should take antidepressants or
xanax or something but i i was always
like i
kind of want to feel this i want to feel
i want to feel everything
it sucks but i want to feel it i don't
want to dull my
instrument it is i'm not knocking
anybody for doing it but i i for me i
was like
i think zany's could be fun here and
there i'm sure but i just i was like i
want to see if i can just
did you get a prescription no i didn't
do any of that because i wanted to feel
it i wanted to just
see how bad what i am it depends if you
go like six months and you're
in a deep dark place then you might want
to but i still want to figure out a way
to get out of that like like this get
out of it daddy where you where you you
put it into your work or put it into
your creativity
whatever you're going through you're all
all of us are going to go
through something we are going to go
through hopefully not like that but yeah
something people go through some [ __ ]
for sure right and
and god forbid it's your child or
whatever but people go through some [ __ ]
and that's called chaos right and then
you how
what are you going to do you can numb
yourself but i
i think people numb themselves in other
ways yeah
whether it's drug not that zany's not a
drug but drugs alcohol
or they get really into bird watching or
some [ __ ] but don't you feel like from
fighting the way you did and i was
listening to you and shane carmen talk
one time about how miserable it was
sometimes like
the worst like you just you're like i'd
rather be anywhere else people are down
the [ __ ] pool and you and i are
stretching to go fight another
monster in a cage right that would suck
but at least that was like
supposedly the fun part but that you're
training your training and all that and
smart and in a way you come out of that
battle tested
mentally strong for sure that's right
like i'll get through it like there were
some dark days last year but
i'll figure it out you figure it out
yeah and i think that whatever it is
that you go through if you
if you embrace it and just but you want
to surround yourself with people like
that
you want to surround yourself with what
you should have learned from this yes
surround yourself with fighters not
technically the term of a ufc fighter
you know what i'm saying fighters i
agree with you yeah because life is a
fight man and
there were some people in our life who
you wouldn't want your foxhole that's
correct
and you learned that you're like where
are you going dude yeah like we we all
had our muskets
and we thought our buddies had our
muskets yeah and then they dropped the
mustard run off
the [ __ ] we're going to fight the south
dude yes
what are you doing we got muskets
where are you going that's right that's
exactly right
or we're in foxholes and it's like we're
there for [ __ ] six weeks
and he ate all the chocolate yeah dude
that was her favorite supposed to ration
that and we're supposed to share this
and then
you ate all the [ __ ] chocolates oh
that's what okay see you later i guess
i ate all the chocolate action i i ate
all the chocolate and actually i don't
like you guys
that's weird that's what some of your
buddies did yeah yeah that's what
happened but i'd rather have that happen
and then you know now this you know
these three at least it clarifies who
who your true people are you know and
you you kind of uh
whittle down on what's actually
important maybe life is that way you
have to do that you know we do a lot of
stuff
for the wrong reasons when when you're i
don't know you find out
but so some of those guys defense so i
don't i don't think anybody knew how to
deal with it you know what i'm saying
like there's no the thing about i can't
go to barnes and nobody like hey do you
have a book
but you you could say that
when friend goes through hell how to
deal with it i'm like oh we actually do
it's uh
friendships for dummies here's a book
yeah like there's there's and you can
call people they give you advice but
nobody's been through it but isn't that
case but everyone's trying their best
isn't that the case with all chaos
though couldn't you say that about all
things
like i'm just saying like uh whatever
happens to you
it's always unique to you it's always a
different thing
even a disease that you didn't expect
yeah and there's other people who have
had that disease and can tell you what
to expect sure you're honest
nothing gets you ready no nothing gets
you ready for the real chaos
for destruction of any kind and people
deal with that
you know i always think about that i
think about stray bullets that take out
a family member or [ __ ] you know
terrorist kills five year
you know whatever the [ __ ] it is you you
you
there is no anecdote for that jordan
peterson said the only
thing you can do is tell the truth in
general like get closer to the truth and
i like that idea
it's just you just clarify [ __ ] and you
get you get less
afraid and more i don't know focused
yeah so it goes right it's all a verb
man i don't know
i don't know it's interesting though i
couldn't sleep last night you know i was
thinking about
if um this is so random if uh i've been
listening this uh documentary on hitler
dude if they would have just given him a
scholarship for his
art this vienna school of the art so
many people would be [ __ ] scared
he didn't get into the vienna school and
then he had hatred in his heart and
that's when he went went back do you
know why
same thing if charles manson just got
that [ __ ] record deal do you know why
six people didn't get in he couldn't
draw human figures he was really good at
drawing buildings and stuff have you
seen someone's drawing
sucked at drawing human figures have you
seen someone's drawing yeah pretty
[ __ ] legitimate i was like how did he
not get in yeah again yeah he was bad at
drawing human figures bad at drawing
human figures did you know he erased
all his past when he became the fuhrer
because
he was pretty average in everything but
he wanted people to look at him like a
god
so any of the stuff before he is a fear
was all erased that's the cult of
personality
that's great they want you to think he's
this higher b any any tyrant rewrites
history and and
changes the truth there's some nice
flowers and i'm not hanging on my
living room vegeta oh what piece is that
hitler yep vegetarian
uh and also uh how about this wouldn't
hurt
animals because vegetarian didn't
believe in eating animals but
tortured and killed many many humans
yeah dude if that teacher could have
just
let him let him in [ __ ] art school
let him in i'm sure he wasn't the worst
it's same with charles manson god damn
it give him a record deal give him the
record deal
sharon tate's alive right now diamond
piece yeah
but where does just those little things
historians obsess over those little
details historians are like if you had
if you had just gotten
if you'd just been an artist but he was
he was basically an incel
he was basically he's tired well there
was a guy who was like
his whole life old older german guy and
he goes yeah i met hitler there's
nothing special
no like he met him like when he was like
in the thing he said the same thing
about stalin
stalin was was a was a bureaucrat who
kept himself even his ambitions kind of
very kind of under
you know he wasn't he was not you never
really described him as anything nothing
special no it was like it was a bunch of
guys and they always they always have
signs that they're the
they're calling like hitler was in world
war one right
and he was in the foxhole and a bomb
came and he said something told him to
walk over here
we'll probably have to take a piss so he
walks over the devil was like
yeah what maybe but i think probably
take a piss or [ __ ] so he walks over
there
bomb comes blows up his buddies goes
this is a sign i should be the leader of
germany
yeah i guess dude when they just had to
take a hot piss and your buddies just
stayed there if you read about world war
one
i've never read an account where it
wasn't hell on earth
you were in trenches the rain would come
you know where to go
and you have to you had to go to the
bathroom there and then bodies would be
there so you'd be living
in a ditch with water with dead bodies
and
feces and you couldn't get clean people
would cry because they couldn't get
clean
and then you just didn't know if you're
going to die and then it wouldn't rain
mustard gas would come over it would
settle in the water so you couldn't
drink any water so people would die
the whole time was a knife hillary yeah
he seemed to got hit with mustard
yes and he went blind and then he found
out that germany had had had surrendered
he was like
what he got pissed he seemed to
according to his superior
charisma though oh my god he was very
happy yeah
yeah have you heard some of his speeches
hillary's no no he was
well dramatic that's how you win people
over like his charisma especially
at a time with the the germans were
going through horrible horrible times
so he was good at marketing his charisma
is so good
as a leader does unfortunately and he
just happened to be a terrible person
but you think obama charisma trump
charisma
like the leaders the best leaders have
that criticism listen to they can speak
to the people
and jeremy at the time you're talking
about a horrible time in in their
existence
and then he goes the jews are the
problem why we're upset and then he
paints this narrative of
why they're evil and they're the reason
why we're doing so bad and people go
damn he's kind of right
and that and there you go that's how it
goes and he seemed to enjoy world war
one he's the only person that's ever
said
i he liked it this was a total sociopath
but he could speak
if you see him speak when he would start
giving his speeches it was [ __ ]
drenched in sweat unbelievable like
passionate bring up one of the real
it's unreal i mean no one speaks german
but you just from it you can see it the
past
if you were an actor he's better actor
than like he was an amazing actor daniel
day lewis yeah
daniel davis probably hates that
compared to somebody you see what i'm
saying watch the passion when he's
talking about deutschland uber alice
deutschland over germany overall
look at this the top one yeah watch
watch the way he speaks their outfits
were
fired
foreign
at a time of desperation so you have
this guy coming telling you things you
want to hear
you're like oh this is not going to come
look at this [ __ ] watch this
watch this [ __ ] look at all the
people and
what this is i think this might be the
most famous squash
look at the look at the he came up with
that the swastika
thousand pairs of boots standing heel to
heel look at this waiting for the
furore's final speed
and the high spot comes when after a
detailed review of nazi achievements
hitler cries
my life's fight has not been in vain
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
yeah you really wonder if a guy like
that had some kind of
like people have said the devil the
devil was sort of like
you know he tapped into some dark
[ __ ] art or something
which i don't believe i think admission
is sociopath what's that you just had a
mission with a sociopath
one of those crazy charismatic good
timing the camera the economy was
you know there's a big perfect in a
society that followed
authority blindly yes you know that was
very very disciplined and very
you have a leader like that and whatever
spewing you're buying
craig have you watched that tyrant thing
on netflix yes i have i like that
people are on on its nuts i don't like
the way it's edited i don't know how
they jump around from dictating oh yeah
it kind of like bugs me a little bit
finished give me this guy's story and
then jump to the next step yeah don't
don't talk about saddam hussein and then
jump over to hitler and then
yeah you don't need to do that just
[ __ ]
finish this but that video which i've
seen a million times you ever seen it
when saddam first becomes
president right pm's president and he uh
calls everybody together crying
well no no have you seen that so he
calls everybody together it's on youtube
he calls everybody together
and the guy who's staging a coup against
him to get him out of there
he has him speak and vouch for saddam
everyone's like what the [ __ ] because he
was the guy who was going against it was
gonna run against them
he's gonna stage a coup and what he does
is what people don't know is before that
what
saddam did it is took his wife and his
two daughters who were like
13 at the time and he was in prison he
goes if you don't
speak for me at this thing i'm gonna
have these soldiers here rape your wife
and your two daughters in front of you
and then we're gonna kill him so what do
you want to do
nice guy so the guy goes all right i'll
do it so not only is he going to do it
but then he goes i want you to come up
with lists who helped you out so he
comes up with a whole list there's like
10 guys on that list
you can get up and talk and say how you
were wrong and how i'm the real
president
and then you can read off those names
and guys like where are you going to
read off things just read off the names
reads off the names and as he's reading
it they take it out right the [ __ ]
military comes in
and the guys are you're seeing grown men
crying
because they're like what the [ __ ] no i
didn't the real names in these these
military picking the guys up taking them
out she's like oh were they doing them
well they took him out back
and they shot him all in the face
intense
total his hero was stalin he had a
library on stalin
so so if you [ __ ] up your family was
killed
nice intense [ __ ] but yeah that that
that uh
tyrants thing that i've seen good
documentaries that ain't one they bounce
all over the place
and it's also like you're giving me the
blueprint how to be a terrible
dictator yeah like this is the blueprint
like literally step by step how to be an
[ __ ] yeah
well and then the the way it was edited
who did that dude
it's jumping all over the place those
sociopaths are if you look at the most
a lot of the leaders i'm sure napoleon
was a sociopath
all politicians first of all all the
ones the ones like that
you know all politicians are compromised
every single one is is has to get to
that level
their a narcissist like to get into
politics is insane
yeah you gotta be a narcissist some
people are gonna
change the world i think originally they
do and then they get a certain point
where you gotta be compromised to get to
power level you wanna get power corrupts
right
obama but i do think obama had good
intentions got a certain level and got
compromised
yeah i don't know yeah or or it's a
dirty
it's a dirty game that's what i'm saying
he gets it he's like well i won't do
this and this like
yeah yeah you gotta do this and this
past this because we need this and this
you have an agenda and you just have to
compromise it's the dirtiest game in the
world dude
there's a limit to who wants to be
involved that you can set an agenda as a
president and then
and you're gonna that's a good thing in
this country because there's always
pushback
there's a there's a there should be a
refining process to democracy you can't
have
direct democracy you can't have like the
people saying we want this otherwise you
have twitter
and they'd be running things and you'd
be [ __ ] you need a refining you need
the refining
um barrier of the legislative of
of the house of representatives and the
senate and that's that's how it was
which makes sense you know all right jim
what do you got first
all right how are you today cat
i'm good you're quiet over there yeah i
mean i don't have much are you sad panda
today
no i just don't have a lot of contribute
when it comes to like politics i don't
know much about it so i try not to
change
it'll come to you if you're not careful
that's okay well yeah yeah eventually
today even me i've never been into it
and then past five years it's it's we
have no choice
politics will come to you it's very
interesting you're gonna have no choice
eventually or you could you know
you can go through the world and just
like yeah it's not up to me but you know
i think philosophical and political
commitment is coming for all of us you
can try to avoid it but you should know
where you stand and why
it can be a sheet i'm not saying or you
can be a sheep it'll be used
you're just going to be one of the many
that people are going to decide for you
yeah you'll get the set yeah or you'll
get in a position where you have no
choice where people are
we're getting close to that in some ways
all right so brendan you sent this to me
yesterday and i watched this clip
it's marc maron on is it a clip because
this is my because i didn't i didn't
look into it i didn't see it i saw this
i'm like this would be good for the show
yeah but when i saw him like i need to
know the context
there was a clip this was uh mark maron
on tom segura's show do we have the clip
uh there's a clip on youtube somewhere
it's not on this particular
chin because before we talk about marin
who i actually like
and i think he's a great comic before we
talked about maren he's been on this
show and
he's one of my favorite podcasters he
you know him and rogan started the same
year
but i need to see the clip i i saw
others
you know i think that you know you're
your own guy you're your own life
you weren't one of the guys that you
know rented out space and joe's ass
yeah it's just like there's like a human
centipede in austin it's like elon musk
joe rogan and three middle acts
so he's being funny but you seem to do
your own thing yeah
well yeah i mean we have our own you
know our own see people are going to see
that go like look at marion he's bitter
it's like why wouldn't i be
white oh he's a million hundred million
dollars for going i don't know
this is this rival price really it's
rabbit right
it's live brogan's pushing back i don't
know man
so that's fair
he's being funny yes yeah but like yeah
i'm not gonna sit here and
it's definitely best and as the next
shangri-la yeah because
people always forget to finish the
sentence you know hey man i'm moving to
austin
texas yes yeah yeah it's still texas oh
god it's really texas it's really texas
it's like the hipster alamo it's just a
little enclave
it does feel like you're in you're
totally in a different unit like
obviously it's the most time i've ever
spent there usually you come in you do a
weekend of shows right you know
but it's it is not like any other
texas experience you know no i would it
is though i always liked it
i mean you know i i i think what he said
was
funny and he's being silly in in a joe's
joe's fine
joe will be fine my only problem is when
he goes you know them giving
a hundred million to rogaine for his
pushback's going oh really man like
that's the only way i don't agree with
mayor
well um like that's not why rogan got
100 million like you can't say rogan's
not a good yeah but he's
joking i mean obviously we know that
again that's shade for sure
okay it's a little shade but it's fine
but also
i thought it was funny but it's the same
the parts were really funny yeah
um but they're and i do like men but
there is
uh you know rogan's the cool kid in town
and everybody knows he got 100 million
dollars so it's like with drake like
if you're an upcoming rap and not that
mark man's up and coming but if you're
like a rapper that's big in the field
like if you're gonna take shots you're
gonna take shots at drake because
a he's not gonna respond he's he's
killing it
you know and b like he's yeah he's the
head honcho yeah so that's the guy you
shoot
that that's fine that's not gonna that's
all good we're just [ __ ] around
everybody's friends it's well they're
not friends but yeah yeah but they're
fine with each other i mean
mark and joe have known each other for
26 years 27. not friends no
okay but they're not enemies you know
they're not they don't [ __ ] with each
other
i've known those guys together for a
long time and i've had conversations
about them with each other and there's
not there's not animosity it just isn't
there's just they're just different
people
they're very different people with very
different audiences yeah i would agree
there's
one one's jazz one's [ __ ] hundred
percent hard rock different but like
and both are great at people like great
value
well dude both are i mean two again
they're two completely different
i think what mark said was actually
funny and he was being silly and it's
just a podcast and he's saying [ __ ]
but i get i get with mary like
everyone's saying austin's like the end
all be all like
guys it's like you shut the [ __ ] up i
agree with that yeah i'm with him yeah
i'm with him i mean i was like
but the only the only part where i don't
ride with mark was like dude 100 million
for being like uh i guess i don't know
like
come on yeah that's that's okay yeah i
mean that's the issue
with it again though again i don't take
that seriously i don't think mark takes
that seriously i think we're just being
i think that joe joe joe probably
had part of joe's what is it um
what would you say his part of his um
technique and personality is not to push
back
is to let people talk you push back and
say say their thing just push back a ton
if you don't agree with it he's gonna
push back for sure yeah he'll push back
but for the most part he's also well
he likes to take himself out of it and
listen to what the person says and once
you get your point across so he's he has
a lot of
times where if he doesn't agree with you
or if he has if he thinks something else
he definitely can push there's also a
lot more than marriage but there's a lot
of times when he's had people on who he
doesn't agree with i know for a fact
i've seen it where he doesn't agree at
all but he'll let them he'll let them
speak
yeah and then he'll just he'll get their
point and then
part of that is a is what he would
consider good podcasting because
he's he's taking them asking them how
they think
and then listening to them if he starts
pushing back right away they're going to
clam up
they're going to shut down right and
their points aren't getting so if you
have a three hour conversation and
you're going to start shutting people
down what happens is that podcast
becomes one hour
correct so so to so i understand why
he doesn't push back in some cases
because he wants to hear what they have
to say and i know for a fact there are
people where he just is like that guy
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about for sure but he's not going to
shut you down because that's kind of not
his
or hers if he thinks you're out of out
of line yeah
i've seen joe is not afraid i've seen
that when people are lying or when
they're being dismissed
yes yeah 100 yeah but if somebody's a
socialist he's also made a hundred
million dollars to do what he does
it's not my it's not what i it's his
thing but that's his thing it's a
three-hour conversation and what happens
is you
so when he had bernie sanders on who
i've always disagreed with
but when you hear him joe does it joe
voted for him
does and doesn't and some some things
vote agrees and other stuff
yeah but for some something he's a huge
advocate for bernie sanders
and bernie going on joe's show helped
out bernie sanders tremendously
when i heard bernie on joe so what
happened was i was like
he didn't sounds extreme right he
sounded a little bit more
reasonable and so what happens when you
listen to that is that that's what i
like about joe's podcast
is you hear somebody not in five minutes
but in three hours
be able to tell or even an hour or
whatever it was with bernie and that's a
long time
i've never heard him get a chance to do
that on tv so you hear him
be able to work through ideas that's the
value 100
100 that's what's great about podcasting
you get the whole
complete person i mean uh marin had
[ __ ] obama on dude
yeah one of the cool things about rogan
and marin is that when somebody writes a
book
and they're on for three hours you don't
have to read their book you just read
their book you got all
they're kind of all set except for tom
o'neill yeah that is do you want to read
you selling red cap
goddamn yeah because i'm going to have
modern conspiracy social club because
you know he's [ __ ] that book i hear
i've had something read the book
you have them on oh i don't just listen
i know it took him 13 years to write
that book yeah you don't want to just
listen no that doesn't do it justice
there's a lot to go dive into there what
did you think of the book
kind of blows your mind and you know i'm
ballsy charles manson you read that like
holy [ __ ]
everything all those you know the polo
like all that stuff
that they wrote with you know the the
famous manson book
all that stuff yeah uh yeah it's like
it's all
[ __ ] they all they had an agenda
like the prosecution
came up with this whole narrative just
to push this and make him seem like this
demon
obviously not a great guy but a lot of
it was just marketing and
you know [ __ ] wow yeah tom o'neil
goes
balls deeper i got i can't wait to read
it so i might it's on my mind
they got to do a small like a mini
series documentary like seven part
series it would crush dude
i bet i i i think that's what no i think
that's what he said they're doing
good i'm gonna read it what's next
so we were talking about jeff bezos i'm
so striated right now now you're lucky
i mean i look good keep studying
yourself
well i keep saying myself because i'm so
[ __ ] white it's hurting my eyes
i'm going snow blind go on jeff bezos
uh went to the edge of space like
richard branson did he didn't
technically go into space yeah they're
not going to suspect he went a little
further oh did he go further and brave
yeah i think it was like uh 10 miles or
something
just like a little more just sister
dominance
so when he landed they held a press
conference and he said he wanted to
thank all of the
amazon employees as well as the
customers because they're the reason why
he was able to
go into space but the way he said it was
um is it was wearing that cowboy hat
i don't know but he basically kind of
joked saying thanks to the amazon
customers because you guys were the ones
who paid for this
yeah because you know people are very so
much more money i haven't paid much tax
apparently from what i hear i don't
think amsterdam sees any taxes no cause
they've been able to move
they play country off country we'll
bring all our business over here yeah
smart guys
don't pay taxes yeah but that that
warren buffett didn't
he didn't when the rest of us do the
schmuck [ __ ] i understand
facebook didn't that's an issue for me
you guys want to hear it or watch it
yeah
and then i also i want to thank
uh every amazon employee
and every amazon customer because you
guys paid for all of this
so seriously for every amazon customer
out there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
and then do you see theo's tweet go to
theo's tweet about this
it's hilarious it's so funny
hold up he's talking about the
peso keep going down
look four white dudes going to space
shake my head at least get a
viet or a dope ass brother and y'all
squad just four white guys going to
space
oh there you go that's a white woman
right man
okay okay so there was a photo that was
going viral where it looked like
the bed at one of the olympic centers
that we're gonna host
uh host all the athletes were made out
of cardboard and somehow a rumor got
started that
the japanese government is putting in
cardboard
beds to try to prevent athletes from
having sex while they're there
and one of the olympic athletes he's a
gymnast actually
uh went on to his bed jumped on and said
it's fine you can do whatever you want
on these
yeah but even if they are out of
cardboard do you really think that's
going to stop people from right that's
what i was thinking
i would do it on a bean bag here we go
yeah in today's episode of fake news at
the olympic games
the beds are meant to be anti-sex
they're made out of cardboard yes
but apparently they're meant to break at
any sudden movements
it's fake fake news fake news
from northern ireland guarantees from
balfous or something yeah and apparently
they you know
at those olympic villages they give out
condoms every every olympics because
you know it's just these elite athletes
having sex like ponies
and they're like well we're giving them
out but we we don't want them to use
them we want them to take them home just
in case it's like yeah okay
like a souvenir yeah come on yeah it's
fine i want a super baby out of that
like a super olympics gifted i'm sure
i'm sure there's been a bunch
why not so this girl
made a tick tock about the time she was
on a flight
going from nashville back home she sat
next to a guy and she
started to look over at his phone she
says everybody does it
i do it every time yeah she was just
like snooping while he was texting his
girlfriend and she started reading the
conversation
and she starts to see that the
conversation is about
her and the guy sitting next to her is
telling his girlfriend that he's sitting
next to a fat ass and that he doesn't
think the plane will be
a big girl no what's wrong with him
hello everyone
i was just sitting in my car and i just
remembered something that happened to me
so about a month ago i was on a plane
coming back from nashville and i
was sitting on the plane and this guy
sits next to me and it's just me and him
like in the row so
like we weren't sitting next to anyone
it was just me and him and he has his
phone out like way out in front of him
like where i can see it
before anyone comes for me for like
looking at someone's phone like when
they're sitting next to me everyone does
it and if you say you don't you're lying
so shut up yeah i do it
anyway i'm sitting next to him and i i'm
reading his text with his girlfriend
and she's asking him how the flight's
going you know just casual conversation
like that
and then i look over and she says how's
the flight going and
he says too small with this fat ass next
to me
like he was talking about me here i got
it zoomed in a little bit more for y'all
it says see
too small with this fat ass next to me
and she said
hahaha tell her about keto
what and you can't really see like the
rest of the conversation but
he continued to type out i'll be all
right don't think we'll make it off the
ground
it's pretty funny she's also not heavy i
know that's
my guy's doing it because she's a hot
chick right she's an attractive girl
so he's texting his girlfriend like i'm
nexus warlock
when he's next to a hot girl yeah if you
tell your girl like
i mean if you text your girl man i get
this hot chick right next i'm just gonna
freak the [ __ ] yeah i wouldn't be
surprised i'm next to this dragon
and it's also he's probably just trying
to be funny and entertain her
yeah whatever all right
i just saw this this morning this
councilman
said the n-word i'll just play
alabama no i'm saying where did he say
that though
inside of meeting wife puts herself in
politics no way in here missing things
on facebook so this guy's talking about
this councilman's wife putting like
political stuff on facebook
so he's like don't talk about my wife
and then it goes from there he
attributes it to you
if you don't want your family involved
my wife
my wife can do what she wants to do
she's a big girl she can take care of
herself
and i'd appreciate it if you
if you want to talk to me about what i
do you can talk to me about
what i do i'm big enough to take care of
myself
against lbgtq she said that in one of
those groups
yeah and she calls us inward let's get
to the n word
i mean hey
yeah he's never going to work again huh
oh i i think he was quoting but somebody
called him
so he said so he was caught somebody
called somebody else a black person
called somebody else was black
that word and he said so what do you
guys think of that because that was used
the n word he goes he's saying is there
actually an
a house n word here because that's what
somebody called them
and nobody and i think he's saying
nobody talked about that
i still can't be you can't be doing that
well he was repeating what somebody
called him
right right he was repeating the word
so so he was repeating the word he was
not saying the word
if you're repeating that someone here
called that person
an n word right that's a very different
thing than using it
very different in my opinion and we've
gotten to a point where it's so crazy
where if you repeat
ooh i'm not okay with that for him as an
older white man to get him and
even to repeat it like just don't you
think he should have said
and instead of the actual i don't know i
don't think he should be
you would never do that i wouldn't do
that because of this new
this you would never do that hysterical
no you wouldn't do that but this is a
new hysterical
no no but b you want to do that 10 years
ago you can
there are people who could say the word
you could say this is a terrible word
that guy just said this word so 10 years
ago you go go that just
that guy just used said such and such
you could say n-word
and you could say that today you get in
trouble just for saying it
but what you could say is that i just
said what that guy said and i i think
it's crazy that you get in trouble for
repeating what somebody said when you
don't have the intention for me it's
about intention
it's about intention and you shouldn't
be sanctioned for
saying words just that we've gotten so
crazy with this [ __ ]
and it's unbelievable to me so you'd be
pretty stupid to say that in this
climate
in today's world it might be stupid
because we're so woke that you can get
destroyed off
over twitter over some saying repeating
what somebody else said
even in disapproval like the guy from
netflix
who said this and everybody knew he
wasn't saying the word
he was repeating the word and saying
this is a bad word
and just by saying it was a bad word he
got fired
he lost his livelihood to be able to
take care of his kids so
[ __ ] that that netflix one's weird yeah
yeah definitely
have complaints it's mob mentality and
it's not
stopping uh racism it's [ __ ] the
netflix
guy he had prior complaints yeah there's
a prior complaint about him using that
one yeah i looked into that too that was
horse [ __ ] too
okay that guy was no that guy just
wasn't liked maybe
but that guy wasn't a racist and
everybody [ __ ] knew it and he still
got fired because everybody's gutless
what kind of prior complaints do you
have jen
some other black that what i read was
some other black employee
the people said i felt uncomfortable but
he had it was more about his
he just wasn't he was a boss and some
people didn't like him
that's what goes on here please just
just that guy is a
as a [ __ ] city councilor in the
government it's like
yeah he was pissed he he was he was soft
not smart not smart um
but let's move on let's move on indeed
um so
young oku who's that kicker for the
falcons
his korean right yeah someone stole his
jeep
but then he just posted about just
please return my cleats that's all he
wants back
to play football dope like custom cleats
do you just leave us
oh [ __ ] that sucks damn did he did any
any luck i didn't hear anything yet
it's like and this is old but it's just
funny i saw this it's been like making
the rounds on social media
okay sam triple posted this so i saw i
had this ready to go and i saw sam post
i'm like damn it let me see it funny
okay
[Laughter]
so dope but it's funny that's so stupid
i like this guy how do they know it's
gay though i literally watched it 15
times to find out all right
well rudy you might be gay hey rooney
conor mcgregor posted that he had his
lamborghini out in
have you seen this i have a question for
you on this jesus christ the question is
ready now that's 2.7 million dollars now
here's what i think
well i i think let me ask you this what
are the chances he paid nothing for it
oh posting yeah it
lamborghini doesn't need any marketing
they could always use marketing
he's posting about it getting conor
mcgregor how much would you how much
would
it cost to get conor mcgregor to do an
ad for you i can promise you it's over a
million dollars
right so for a customized lamborghini
not but he
he bought it i think he got it for free
i don't think so
either they're not going to give it to
you for free they might have they'll
lend it to you yep they're not going to
give you could have lend it to them too
[Music]
counter has so much money man it's not
as big as i thought it'd be though
so it's it's still cool as hell but i
thought on the picture it looked like
those giant yachts those that rich
people have
he got 27 2.7 million
like likes on the picture alone that's
worth a lot of money
to lamborghini i think i don't think
larry needs any help selling those
i would be like i'll post about it and
just give me he definitely got a deal on
it i guarantee that guaranteed
look at that [ __ ] boat though it's
pretty dope damn
there's a five more round we made boats
by the way yeah
yeah thing's sick it's smaller than i
thought though well the beast is here
it's here nigeria well the devil was
actually arrived
hitler returned as a goat with five
[ __ ] horns
that is so freaky to me that is so
freaky
does he have red eyes hey starfish head
are you [ __ ] kidding me
that thing's [ __ ] it looks cool it
looks innocent too so if you had a
scarier face
that's magnus right now he looks cool
no they're definitely gonna kill him
gotta die he's gotta die he's gonna die
he's gonna slit his throat but well he's
cute he might
be the sign of the apocalypse it might
be time
that's a bad omen five-warmed ram
horned ram um i just saw this too
oh no so there's those celebrating
fat girl summer and that's the post
right there
okay i just know how long we promote
this unhealthy lifestyle man
she's young too dude how old is she like
when she's 40 this ain't going to end
well
daddy she's 20 something
yeah there's oh
there are people who uh i've seen people
from high school okay 33.
okay i've seen people you ever see
people who you went to school with or
college and
never and they were great and then you
see them and you're like
and they're literally 100 pounds heavier
it's always kind of shocking
it's tough and you're always like ah
why throw you some curveballs i mean
she's talented as [ __ ] i just don't get
why
remember she got blowback because she
was going on a juice diet
all the fat people are like how dare you
like heaven for [ __ ] you should get in
a healthier shape
yeah what's this this is a huge thick
bear
we're tagged quite a bit of this board
he's getting ready fatty
dude he's so fast wait till he does this
though
let's see how big he is right here dude
he's so fast
so big he's been getting in some trash i
don't think nature feeds you that well
does he
it's the first band that is god he's
[ __ ] huge
or is it a pregnant female might be his
belly is dragging on the ground
if there were nuts out the back i didn't
see any nuts
bear nuts you know what they call a male
bear anybody ten cents
what they call a male bear what a bore
you're welcome
nick saban yeah no he didn't get a
million dollar deal
the quarterback who's never played a
dead rushing a million dollars in
endorsements already
from that new law that the ncaa for the
name and likeness
yeah so this kid's never played it down
and he already has a million dollars
endorsements
good good rule right yay or nay i think
so
yeah there's gonna be trouble for sure
because think about this kid
now he's a millionaire you know like the
what does it do for your motivation you
mean or no it's just
you know it can be a little weird on
campus right team cohesion
yeah think about that though kids are
used to it now because tick tockers and
all these kids are making so much money
uh yeah in football it's a little
different though you know you have a
hundred guys on the roster
matter million i feel like it was a
matter of time social media makes you
rich
i mean think about how much money tim
tebow would have made
for sure though yeah
always was anyway though i don't know
that money maybe uh play the video of uh
of playing uh yeah he finds out this kid
got a million dollars back with ale.com
uh today nick saban said that his
quarterback has earned almost a million
dollars so far
in nil his face how have you seen that
play out
uh with recruiting and the potential for
other schools brands to uh earn players
some money
that number just blew me away so
you didn't prepare me for that um
that's amazing i made a million dollars
and hadn't started a game yet
wow um
i mean i don't even know what to respond
to that but great for him
[Music]
it is neat the players can make money
now
and profit you know off of their hard
work and yeah
basically everybody else in america gets
to do so
you know i'm excited about it i think
it's very challenging
trying to figure out it's gonna be tough
because kids in alabama
make more money than kids that ole miss
i was asked earlier about it
i said you know i'm i'm excited for it i
wouldn't want to be compliance
departments but
let's give me a nightmare he didn't like
that question no they're gonna try to
figure it out
yeah that was a tough one that's funny
man
is that it that is it come see me kids
deserve good where are you gonna be too
much
come on next week thursday friday
saturday tacoma washington with the crew
chappelle lacy backflip lacey david
lucas will be there that's july 29th
through the 31st
tacoma washington dunham in north
carolina august 19th
through the 21st there's a camera in my
way then tickets just went on sale at
the comedy store in la jolla la jolla
california comedy store is august 27th
through the 29th and that's uh two shows
friday two shows saturday two shows
sunday oh
sunday sunday love it they do fridays
it's a great place to be
my favorite my favorite san jose improv
september 9th through the 11th
the big dog san antonio texas september
24th through 25th
them in denver vegas those dates got
rescheduled so vegas is now
officially wise guys vegas october 7th
through the 9th
breast october 15th through the 17th
honolulu hawaii end of october
get your tickets kids but tacoma
washington next week thursday friday
saturday tickets at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com ontario california
improv
july 29 3031. come get some luis alvarez
opening up for me
uh it's funny and kevin mack is going to
be in my mc
houston texas improv august 19 20 21.
see you there and american comedy club
august august 4th one show that's a
wednesday
come out you get the tickets up there
daddy yeah i got to get the tickets up
there let's do that
job help me i'll get some tickets up all
right all right love you guys